okay
let's do it
okay ladies gentlemen
welcome to a live episode
[Music]
is
[Music]
what's up y'all i know you can't believe
this
coming in late coming in strong
started up freaking almost midnight here
on the west coast but it is what it is
um i just moved i didn't get to do an
episode so i was like i'm gonna do an
episode like this live
whoever finds it finds it it is what it
is
you know what i mean but i welcome
everybody and thank you for being here
and
this is a live episode
all right we will have the singing mic
all night
all night all day what's up everybody um
i know you're here you're here with me i
got the chat open
um i'm here for those that are listening
and you didn't get to experience it live
i'm sorry but i want to thank everybody
for coming to riff and with griffin
i stream daily on twitch in case
you know for the people that watch
twitch you all already know
i stream on twitch daily and that's that
eric griffin gaming
so make sure you check that out eric
griffin gaming um
on twitch and then i put those on
youtube i just got finished playing a
great game with steve
stevie wiebe and i played summer some
war zone and with my buddy brian from
new york
and we just won a trio so i'll have that
video up on
my thing but this is live full effect
full effect and direct this is i do i
use you know what y'all don't know this
but i record my episodes on sunday
anyway and i release them on monday
i just got sometimes i just have a
complete stream of consciousness and i
just do it
and so you know i'm here right now just
doing it like this because this is how i
would record the episode anyway
i usually record my episodes in one take
and then i put them out and here they go
so
i say hey you know what let me just do
it live and this is already out it's
already done it's already edited i don't
even got to think about it
i'm in my new place and so i i don't
even have it set up i had the green
screen set up but that's about it you
know because i had to do
this project and i had to have ready to
go
you know but i moved um i just want to
talk about the move a little bit
just moving um and welcome chat by the
way you people that are watching live
i'm with you i'll try to look over as
much as i can and i appreciate you guys
being here
uh with me as i'm doing this on this
late night adventure
um and you know if you like it like it
right now and share it because people
might come
uh and today's episode is brought to you
by my brand new sponsor i got a sponsor
betterhelp.com and i'll talk about
better help later but check out
betterhelp.comgriffin
if you need some counseling some therapy
uh it's uh some great stuff that they
got going on and if you get a 10
discount for being a riffing with
griffin
fan but we'll talk about that later
because i got to do a live read but
anyways i moved guys i moved so
um here's the thing about the move all
right moving sucks all right and
my last place i had all these stairs and
i had a weird stair so there was like a
a a 180 degree turn on my stairs so you
go up
you turn and it's you know it's fun it's
great whatever but the problem is when
you have to move
the furniture that's upstairs they have
to somehow get it through that
and then there's so i had so i had two
stories
right and so you had to walk up the
stairs to there and then on
in the building that i lived in you also
had to walk up the stairs to get there
so i don't know so i had this moving
company they were great actually
uh but it wasn't too much trouble i
don't even give them a plug good
neighbor
good neighbors moving company all right
giving them a plug because
i i had a great experience other than a
couple of things you know
but my first thing is like so the movers
show up they're late
okay so they're supposed to be there at
8 30.
dude calls me his name's angel shows up
at nine with the truck and two dudes
so all right so the guy i'm talking to
on the phone that i set everything up
with
i don't want to be uh i don't want to
stereotype whatever but
he sounded like a white guy all right so
he sounds like it's a white guy that
runs the company right
so okay first of all you ever try and
like we don't no one wants to be racist
okay we none of us
we and and anytime there's like
stereotypes and anytime this type of
thing you try to avoid them
but then when it's thrown in your face
you find yourself being like am i racist
but you're not trying to be racist it's
like for instance you know it's like you
you walk up on a you walk upon a black
dude he eaten chicken and watermelon he
got a fat
fat white girlfriend and two kids that
look like they from different baby mamas
and you're like
ugh what do i do right you know actually
i've had to
it's like are you being racist if you're
like well see but you know it's weird
how it's weird how you're where your
mind goes
it's like i took my buddy vinnie i had
him on the podcast vinnie and i we went
to when he did the podcast we went to go
eat sushi in downtown culver city
so it's pandemic so it's outdoor eating
you know so
outdoor seating so we sitting out here
right we we walk up to the sushi
restaurant
and there's like a stern-faced asian guy
and there's people walking up and down
the place right
and he's kind of standing out there and
it's one of those things where you're
like okay you're standing in front of an
asian restaurant
and you're looking for somebody that
works there and it's that moment where
you're like
does he work here you know it's like
table for two
how is it or are you helping us you know
so
it was just like this weird moment so
yeah that's what i'm saying you have
these kind of moments all right
so i bring this up to talk about these
the movers come
okay and i and this is on me
i'm realizing i was misjudging okay
because okay all right there is the
reason why
well i i won't even talk about it like
that i'll just tell you exactly
how it all came about so um the movers
get there
they get to my place at like nine so i
want to take care of them early because
they're touching your personal
belongings i don't know these people
and i want it to go smoothly so i call
them up
you know i say hey man i'm i'm
my girl's going to uh starbucks let me
get you guys something there's three of
you right what do you guys want tell me
what you want
he's like i could first of all i could
tell he's shocked
he got surprised in his voice up top of
like oh
okay bro you know and he's by the way
they're all latino okay so if you hear
me do like a weird accent it's because
he said bro a lot he was he was latina
his name was angel okay
so he was latino as a mother so he's
like okay bro
you know and i go uh what do you guys
want and he goes anything
so when you already when you already
feel uncomfortable that somebody's
buying you something
you don't want to put in an order you
just want to go hey get me whatever you
want to get me
so i say no man tell me what you want
i'll get you what you want
and he says like like questionably he
goes
carmel frappuccinos you know he was like
you know frapp you know and i was like
okay cool i'll get you three of those he
was like
oh okay all right so they get there we
give them the coffee it's cool all right
the guys get out the truck and
immediately i'm like
my brain is already going to some place
the dude's name is angel
the other guy his name might as well
have been spider and the other guy
little puppet i mean that that's what
they look like dude had neck tattoos
wife beater they they had no braces on
then they had no gloves
they you know what i mean they had
nothing to protect themselves from
lifting stuff
dude so i'm immediately like okay
so i think i put him at ease because i
gave him the coffee they were already
like bro
thank you you know it was cool so then
we started now i know that the owner of
the thing didn't tell them
that my all the stairs situation
you know didn't tell them that at all
you know what i mean so he was like so
they were already like whoa
and then i have a lot of stuff i have
heavy stuff i have this big heavy couch
that has three
sections and as heavy as [ __ ]
all right so then they start
it take it takes forever i got quoted
for three hours
by hour four we hadn't even finished
packing my place
to even come over to the new place so
like it's getting you know whatever then
i say to the dudes
i go hey you guys want in and out you
know and their their reaction was like
like what you know because i i just i
feel like
spending some extra money to like get
them to do the job right or feel like
i'm not treating them like whatever
you know i thought that was important to
do so i got in and out i sent rachel
to get some in it now we got you know
three double doubles with french fries
center so we finally got everything
loaded we get over to the new place
this is now taking forever we're going
into extreme overtime
my quote is already gonna be triple what
i'm gonna have to pay because of what's
going on they get another guy to come
he's funny you know they're like i'm
cracking jokes with them and we're sort
of having a good time as good as you can
have if you're working and you're doing
like a job like this where you have to
move
you know what i mean so all right the
job finishes
one day broke one of my tables i have a
a a living room end table
these dudes break it okay they broke it
not only did he break it
but they broke it when i wasn't even
around and then they threw it away
okay so he it was like unsalvageable so
he just made an executive decision and
threw my table away
i saw the picture and i was like damn
they broke the legs and everything
now quiet as is kept but i'm saying it
publicly now
i don't really care i didn't care
because these i want to get new tables
but still the principal over they broke
my table you know what i mean
but i didn't i'm not i wasn't going
karen out yet all right
so they broke the table fine
so then the guy calls me at the end they
finally finish it's late
i give the guys some of my dvds too i
give him three ugly truth dvds my first
comedy special which you can buy on
airgriffin.com by the way
so i give them the my uh comedy i give
them the comedy dvds
and they're making jokes too one of the
guys one of the guys was hilarious i
think his name was george
he did not want to do any work i almost
felt like the other guys
asked him yo man you want to come work
and we'll you you'll get tipped you'll
get some money
cause like he was lifting the couch and
he was like bro my back i can't do it
the other guy was like dude come on man
so they had to get the other guy who
obviously worked there
and this guy was just funny they also
the three of them had
they were all playing music right on
their phones just blasting the music on
their phones with no regard
all of them playing different rap rap
music
and old school stuff too you know like
the dude's like listening to like if you
think you're
lonely now you know and then the other
one was listening to like some
you know whatever rap songs and they all
had different things and i was like all
right let's just get this done you know
what i mean
so the dude was funny that one didn't
even want to do the work
and he didn't know then they making fun
of me i know they were making fun of me
because one guy was like
the main guy was like dude have i seen
you on uh comedy central
and i was like yeah you probably seen
workaholics right oh yeah
yeah you know and then the other guy
clearly had never seen workaholics
before in his life he could care less
he just didn't want to do this menial
labor job he was done
okay and he just like whatever you know
and so at the end of the day i'm giving
him the dvds one of the guys was he felt
he was
he was gassing me up like he was excited
sign it bro sign it so i can have it and
be like oh i
met this guy and i was thinking to
myself whatever i tip him out
i actually gave them all a hundred
dollars each okay because
that that's how much this [ __ ] was
anyway if you think about that
four so i tipped out four hundred
dollars all right
they leave next day okay
wait i'm talking to the owner
of the thing okay talking to the owner
right or the guy the dispatch guy
whoever
he hears about how they broke my table
and they also broke one of my lamps so
they broke two things
the guy says i'm only authorized
to offer you 50 i'm just telling you
being straight up if you don't accept
that you have to call and you have to do
a claim
i was like all right so then
i'm about to pay with a credit card and
a dude and the dude says i go you don't
want me to just pay cash
he goes well if you pay cash you get a
discount
so the guy he hits the guy back up and
the guy gives me a hundred dollars off
because i paid cash here's my problem
so these [ __ ] break my stuff
and he can only give me a 50 discount
but if i pay cash he now can authorize a
hundred
like come on man there's so many moving
horror stories
like some people move they get their
[ __ ] stolen or some people move
and then they like quadruple the price
even more
that and but you're you're stuff's
hostage they go well we're not gonna
take your stuff off the truck unless you
pay this
or they leave your [ __ ] outside and what
are you gonna do last minute you know so
that's how they hijack people so
finding a good moving company is uh
strange
so all right here's where i am taking
the blame from my
foolish thoughts so i have a little
money box it's not a money box but
i keep changing it and i've just put
changing and it's it's metal it's an
old-school
money box and i just have a bunch of
changing the quarters pennies you know
you know it's heavy as hell i left it on
the counter so they and they these guys
just they pack stuff for you too
i go i'm taking everything they don't
even care they just grab [ __ ] and throw
it in a box
i can't this morning i wake up i can't
find my money box
i'm telling rachel i can't find my money
box rachel where the hell's my money box
at right
she's like it's somewhere you know and
i'm like they stole my money box
then i come upstairs because they also
put my clothes in the thing
and i'm looking through my my clothes
and i go my raider jacket is missing
immediately you know i'm being racist
i'm being stupid
because i'm thinking the latino guy
stole my
raider jacket you know raiders you know
what i'm thinking they saw this jacket i
was like i'm keeping this jacket
like how stupid right of course i find a
raider jacket
and rachel finds the money box like
here's the money thing
and i was already like damn it in my
mind i was being like
like so i'm being stereotypical
stereotypical i'm ready to carry out
you i'm about to carry this company the
hell out on the phone
but turns out i was just being stupid
so kudos to good neighbor
moving company they did a great job the
dudes i won't say they were like
like super professional but you know
you're not getting a harvard grad
when you uh to move to move for you
you know what i mean and even that's
done what i just said but the point is
they got the job done the dudes were
cool you know and i
i tried to treat him as well as i could
probably went above and beyond what most
people do
but i did it you know but they called me
bro like
50 times you know what i mean or like
one of them was like mr eric
i i think it's funny when somebody call
you mr eric
you know like what are you talking about
so anyways
that's the story of moving so here we
are i'm in my new place uh you know
i love it you know what i mean it's a
bigger uh well we need to talk about
that because i'm not trying to floss but
i did it i moved
it's done all right now uh what else is
going on make sure you please share
like you know there's 269 of you guys
watching right now so make sure you uh
hit them likes
[Music]
all right what else has been up so i was
driving
down the street now the homeless
situation in l.a is getting crazy maybe
it's always been like this
and because of it's a pandemic they're
not
being strict about where people can be
or where they can pitch their tents
i don't know if the homeless situation
is you know any more worse than it
always is
and it's pretty bad right
so i'm driving by you know
this encampment under the freeway and
i'm seeing all these tents
and i'm like damn tense tense then i
start seeing different sides of the
tents and stuff
and then i'm like one of the tents
this sucker was a pavilion you know what
i mean this sucker had a concierge desk
i felt like the tent was so big
and i thought to myself damn dude stop
flossing
like imagine you homeless and you're
living in a little [ __ ] tent
and then three tenths down do got a four
bedroom tent
you know what i mean are you like well
damn dude like even on that level
people are you know people flossing even
on that level right oh wait a minute
we got a super chat
[Music]
oh
[Music]
all right matic productions my boy matic
productions he sent some beats for me
so when i get to super chats i'm gonna
throw on this beat
and we gonna get it going but he sent me
some dope beats and if you want to send
me some dope beats be sure to send me
those beats at
eric airgriffin.com email me
[Music]
all right anyways so you driving down
the street man
again i don't get it like i go like
this dude this tit it just looked
ridiculous like it was the biggest 10 on
the block type of thing
and i just thought damn even in homeless
even
people that are like disenfranchised and
people that are like they down on their
luck and they got to live underneath a
freeway
there's still a hierarchy even there
that was like craziness
i was like meg fix your tent situate
like come on man you don't could be
flossing this hard
and some people got like they got the
tents and they building fences around
the tents
like you know they had that wood i was
like my goodness like this is like
what what is happening
say what's happening in this situation
uh oh super chat just came in y'all
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
[Music]
is
all right so
i don't know i mean what are we going to
do about this homeless situation i mean
don't you ever like i always feel like
what am i doing
am i doing enough i don't think we're
not i'm not nobody's doing enough if you
think about it
and we got to sort of hear no evil see
no evil say no evil attitude about
the homeless and it's like we're so
we're so
used to it now we're so just like you
pull up on our freeway
on ramp you go put up your window if it
was down because somebody's right there
with a sign and you're just like boom
and even if you're somebody that likes
to give because i usually like if i have
change and money in my little thing
in my car i would that's what i use it
for i'll be like oh here comes somebody
that needs something i go here's a
dollar man boom
you know but it's like is that absolving
me
from my societal obligation to make sure
my fellow man
is moving forward and being helped
probably not
for sure not so it's tough man
it's tough and once again i don't
necessarily think that
the uh homeless like somebody said in
the chat they think the homeless have
taken over
but i don't think i just think that i
don't think it's any worse than it's
ever been
i mean obviously it's worse because
people have like we're going through
some tough times and people are really
struggling right now with all the
closing of
businesses and people can't work and in
in you know the evictions and
okay i get that but i think the whole
homeless situation
was still pretty bad even before this
but then you had these city ordinances
where it was like
you can't be under this freeway you know
like if you're under this
freeway the cops will come and they'll
kick people out
so i think that that's um
what happened in in that situation and
now they're not
um what do you call it they're not
enforcing that anymore because what are
they going to do with these people
what are you going to do in the middle
of a pandemic what you're going to take
people to jail like it don't even make
sense
so the homeless are like well this is
where i'm living right now i'm staying
right here
with my big ass tent so
i don't know man
chad is saying i should interview a
homeless person and i hope you guys last
week i was talking about the mandalorian
and i see people in the chat talking
about i hope you guys
watch it i mean if you're into it i mean
i really enjoyed mandalorian that sucker
was great
that sucker that been alone is so good
so good
you know so so good all right want to
talk about
what else did i want to talk about i had
some topics i wanted to talk about
um first of all any questions in the
chat since we're here this is like
that we're live right now for you guys
that are listening later if you didn't
catch it live
i might start doing more of these um but
you know if you didn't catch it live
um you know we are we're we're here on
riffing with griffin
i'm live on youtube right now on the on
the rift from a griffin youtube page
that's eric griffin comedy so make sure
you check that out
um no workaholics is not still around
and and i don't know if there's any
plans to do like you know how they bring
shows back like will and grace and all
that kind of stuff i don't think that's
uh
going to be good somebody asked me what
do i think about cyberpunk let me answer
that
i got cyberpunk video game i played it
on eric griffin gaming
which you can catch me on twitch i
played on eric griffin gaming and
i don't know man like i don't know about
that game it reminds me of gta grand
theft auto
because it's open world but i hate hate
hate the story i hate having to go
through
all this nonsense and talk to people i
hate talking to
i hate my character talking to someone
and me having to sit there
and enter you know okay skip skip skip
skip skip i hate it
but some of the missions are really hard
i can't get past this one mission
so the game's beautiful looking it's
well crafted
i mean i i i can't give it back because
i bought it online
i wish it was like dvds and you can
return that kind of stuff but you can't
so i'm playing cyberpunk and i i don't
know the jury's still out on it
i just i play a lot of warzone i love
warzone so i played every single day
so i'm trying to mix in other games i've
tried to play cyberpunk but
i don't know i think um i think the
height it was overblown
i think there was too much hype too much
hype
you know and if i had if i had to like
if you had to ask me
if it was only two choices good or bad
i'd pick
bad you know it's it's i don't know
but i'm starting to have a little bit of
fun when i play it so i think that it's
uh
you know you could try it out we'll see
try it out
okay what else has been going on so you
know
this is something i just wanted to talk
about and this is delicate i'm talking
about this live so i got to be
measured and cautious about what i say
but i still record
i usually record my podcast in one take
anyway so it don't even matter
but you guys know the actress ellen page
she just
now she's like i don't know if she's
transgender or if she's
let me look it up i don't know what it i
don't know what she classifies herself
as now but she now
is going by um elliott
you know let's look it up ellen page um
you know news you know so she
yeah so yes so she has come out as
transgender
and she now wants to be called elliott
page
okay how do i feel about this the real
question is what does it matter what i
feel about it
that's really how i want to feel about
it but no because of social media in the
news
they jam this kind of stuff down your
throat to me we should normalize it and
it'd be like who cares
it's like being gay i don't care if
you're gay
who cares be gay do you
all of us whatever our proclivities are
whatever little preferences and things
that we have
we should not have to explain ourselves
to people or be defined by it
we should just be able to do what we do
but no
everything has to be made into a big
deal and right now the transgender
movement is one of those things
you know i get it it's tough it's hard
right but it's like one of these things
where
you know they throw it out in front of
us and then we now we have to deal with
it
and i'm saying like can i take a minute
can i have a minute
to process for instance
i get an example of what i mean so at my
old place
they didn't have electric car charging i
got an electric car
they told me they were going to get get
the electric car charging when they
eventually got it
it wasn't going to be on my regular spot
so i had to switch spots a spot i'd been
parking in
for like six years or longer however
long i was living at that place that was
my spot
i pull into the parking lot i i make i
go in
i pull into my spot it's second nature
when you're going home i'm listening to
audiobooks or even talking on the phone
i'm distracted
i i i'm on autopilot i go to my spot
i had to move my spot for like a week or
two
i kept pulling in and going to that spot
like ugh i don't park here anymore
my bad had to back up go to my spot
because my brain works can i take a
minute
so you want to be elliot page now cool
can i take a minute and get used to it
can i
is it okay that i'm like all right um
or this person doesn't want to
be called this anymore and has decided
to
do this okay i still remember
her or him now i don't know what see as
ellie allen page from the movies and you
know i've even met her a few times
at my boy's house you know so it's like
now we have to now deal with it
and look some people are [ __ ] some
people are like
hateful negative hateful people that
they can't accept anything you know they
think they're doing right they think
they're christian
or whatever they follow and they think
that they're in the right and they act
terrible
those people there's nothing you could
do about those people but there's a lot
of us
and i would say most of us who don't
care most of us are just at home like
why is this a story who cares do you
but because you've made me have to deal
with it so here i
am i gotta be like all right hey you
know somebody says hey did you hear
about that and you go oh you mean to
ellen oh i mean elliot i mean
you're like i gotta get used to it and i
have to get it's like
with um it's like i've known you you
know you
you know about a person for years you
know juno was
that that's like 10 years old now you
know you're a star you you got
nominated for stuff best actress
nominations or whatever she's gotten you
know what i mean
so now all of a sudden we gotta be like
okay it's a dude now okay
so ultimately i feel like we don't
care i think we most of us have a
problem with
being forced to like deal with it
directly
because of being inundated with all this
information all the time
and so you just get to a point where you
know we gotta be like take a moment but
sometimes people are gonna slip up is
what i'm saying
just cause you slip up or just because
you're uncomfortable just because it's a
difficult
or it's like a hard transition or you
don't remember we're not
used to it that don't mean you're a
devil i'm not a monster because
occasionally i'm gonna be like oh
remember ellen page oh that's right it's
a man now
you know what i mean give me a second to
like you know get get it together it's
like
man this is just like daylight savings
all right
daylight savings every time it's
daylight savings for like a week i'm
like this damn
it's five o'clock it's still it's it's
dark
dark as hell out here what's going on oh
yeah we changed the clock it's daylight
savings
and then you get used to it and you
don't even think about it until they
change it again and then you're like my
god it's still
light out it's what five o'clock why
isn't the sun down you know
that's just how that goes
you know what i mean all right before i
move forward i usually do real world
advice from a grown-ass man i didn't do
it this week because i wasn't gonna have
time to uh
um make uh answer any posts but i just
want to tell everybody uh you know
i do this and every time i do my advice
portion of my show
which i could do a couple of questions
here on the chat but i don't trust the
chat
youtube chat is toxic um but
i always tell people don't think
that getting get getting help is
important like getting therapy
is it's not bad for you you know therapy
is great
it helps you organize your thoughts it
helps you
connect the dots with a professional who
understands these things and sees
patterns
they're not going to solve your problems
it's just going to help you get through
them help you understand them and even
if you don't saw them least you have a
better understanding of where it comes
from
and i just because i've been doing this
segment i now have a great new sponsor
so my new sponsor is called better help
all right better help us if you go to
betterhelp.com
griffin you will get a discount
all right you know a lot of things
interfere with our happiness
interfere with our life we're stressed
out about the pandemic we're stressed
out about how we're gonna pay rent
so better help is a place you can
connect in a safe private environment
you're not gonna you don't gotta go sit
in a waiting room and feel
weird and self-conscious that you're in
in uh you know getting therapy you can
start communicating with under 24 hours
too
all right you send a medicine to your
counselor at any time and they will
answer it with a and this is a
professional this is a self-help
this is a freaking therapist all right
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in depression stress
anxiety relationships look even like
transgender issues too if you're
somebody that's transitioning or you're
somebody in your family you're trying to
deal with it
this is how therapy will help you
understand what you're feeling all right
so
i want you to start living a happier
life today so as a listener of reverend
with griffin you'll get 10
off your first month of visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
griffin and that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com
griffin guys better help so thanks to
better help for being a sponsor
so i'm trying to um be out there for you
guys
all right so damn how much time we've
been doing oh [ __ ]
look how fast 30 minutes goes guys
now i was on rick glassman's podcast uh
oh
we got uh
[Music]
somebody's name is yikes
got those likes with that 996
it don't make sense
you like my kids
that's it you only gave 99 cents so
you ain't getting a full rap but thanks
for the super chat
so i was on the great rick glassman's
podcast take your shoes off
i love rick you know rick rick has
become a really dear friend of mine and
he always makes me really emotional you
know with some of his stories and what
he goes through and i just i really am
fond of rick glassman
you know
we were i was on there this time and we
were talking about
look and we were talking about stuff
that in it three days later it happened
because we talked we were talking a lot
about
body positivity and what we feel about
that movement
and what you know and i've talked about
this before but i don't care i mean i'm
just i'm not a i'm not a big fan of
body positivity just on its own things
need to be unpacked
but on social media media you get little
snippets you know you get highlights you
get
sentences with no context you don't get
the
full story the full spectrum because
life is really nuanced
and every case is individual you know
but as a whole i believe that
we all should try to be as healthy as
possible with our diet
with our what we put in our bodies you
know diet uh
our are taking care of ourselves and you
know we're all
a lot of us are falling short of that
and i think that
just body positivity just as a blanket
statement
you know it's i feel like it's applied
in the wrong way
you know it's like you know you have a
this is how it usually happens too
you get someone like adele for instance
adele she big
she a thick chick adele thick
and then you see a person like that go
on interviews and talking about her body
and you know
i don't know if adele actually did that
because i actually have a friend who was
an actress
who was all over the place talking about
body positivity this is what happens
someone like that
like so now
fat people out there they see this
person as a hero
oh look this person is making it and
doing their thing and they're proud of
who they are and what they look like
right but this is what always happens
that person starts losing weight and
getting healthy you know why because
they have to
okay they have to all right they got
they're on tour they're doing tours
adele can't be fat all the time
cause she gotta sing you have to be in
shape jermaine dupri had this great show
about these kids a hip-hop competition
with these kids one of the challenges
was
this performer took him to work out and
he said
look you're on stage you want to do a 30
city tour
where you're on stage for two hours a
night you got to be in shape you got to
keep your stamina you got to so you can
remember the song so you could perform
the songs
it makes sense as a performer right so
someone like adele who she had her baby
and all the stuff she had now she's like
you know she's older you gotta be in
better shape
so they end up leaving the fat army but
then the fat army is sitting back at
home like
well what are you doing you're promoting
diet culture
what now diet culture even in itself
is more nuanced someone hit me up
talking about well diet culture is like
these weird diets that people tell you
to be on these like quick fix diets but
the way they're in the way they're
applying it online to people
so anyway rick and i are talking about
this on this podcast
you know rick and i were talking about
this on this podcast and i said to him
you know what's gonna happen
because i told him this is what happens
these fat these fat celebrities
are always out there talking body
positivity and they always go out and
lose weight
they always go out lose weight and get
healthy and then everybody gets on them
like what are you doing you're supposed
to be
in love with who you are and that's not
what it's about listen
you can love who you are and still be
wrong you can love who you are and still
need to be
in better shape or to be healthier and
so what you love who you are you know
but hitler loved who he was
hitler was probably like i'm the [ __ ]
look at me i'm running a country and i'm
killing people you know what i mean
just because you love who you are it
don't make it right okay so stop with
that
and i said on rick glassman's podcast i
said you know who's gonna
you know and this just is live how you
doing jeremy coleman
it's live i like saying people's name
when i see in their checks they go is
this live
yes live fool anyways
so on glassman's podcast
i said you know who this is going to
happen to it's going to happen to lizzo
i said to him this is gonna happen to
lizzo because she's like
the fat princess everybody loves her
they praise her
and she's now trapped in a corner where
she has to be fat for people to love her
but you know what it ain't gonna last
she is eventually gonna have to be
healthier
and they got on her and she went on a
juice cleanse
for like 10 days you know they showed
her before and after
and before she was fat the after she
wasn't as fat
but still fat like they act like it's
like
they're so stupid so they're getting on
her lizard's promoting diet culture
so this is like where i say where will
advice from a grown ass man i'm giving
out advice right now unsolicited real
world advice
when can we get back to telling people
to go [ __ ] off you know
when can we get back to telling people
mind your damn business about what's
going on here
you know lizzo is like she has
responsibilities of her own to her
family to her life to her career
and she's popular she's gonna she has to
tour she has to go out there
she is not gonna be able to sustain that
form of excellence being that fat
that's just my opinion so she there's
gonna have to be a compromise
of you know what she what she has to do
and and maybe she's gonna be like you
know i don't care i just won't go do as
much concerts
you know if that's what she wants to do
fine but let her do her
if she wants to stay fat that's on her
if she wants to diet and get skinny and
try to try to like take care of herself
that's on her too we need to just leave
people alone
you know it's like we letting these damn
cairns on the internet
run our lives in our world and they need
to shut up i'm so tired of people using
words like toxic
that's the word i can't stand like
because that's the that's a catch-all
like what i'm talking about right now
it's a catch-all so it'll be like
eric griffin was having a toxic
conversation about weight
[ __ ] shut up mind your [ __ ] business
that's what i have to say to you you
know a toxic conversation
you know that's like you talk about
anything and
they call it toxic you know what you're
toxic with your toxic
you know what i mean your culture
culture that's what i'll call it
it's culture culture you know diet
culture whatever culture
you know toxic man culture you know what
your culture
culture is the thing that's ruining
society
uh oh we got a quick you know we got to
do it
this is what we do live guys you know
this what we do live this helps me not
be so angry
are we back at it again tell your friend
we always about that win with this magic
production beat
make your move from your head to your
feet
we got another super chat my man
they're a millionaire is that
five dollars got
all right so it's like
can we leave people alone can we
can we just leave people alone you know
what i'm saying
like why like people are
just trying to live their lives like
stop making people the hero that didn't
necessarily want to be a hero
like you know you know you you you put
out music like imagine the the
pigeon hole how how pigeonholed lizzo is
now she has to be the fat chick champion
you know what i mean
she got to be the one that's got to
always be out there look at me she
it's like every one of her pictures it's
just her with like
rolls you can't even see the bikini top
you know
you just be like what like okay is this
cute to some people sure
is it inspiring to some fat girl out
there who's like oh i don't want to work
out or i have trouble working out or i'm
too busy and it's like
look lizzo did it so i can do it too
okay fine
but there are also other people who are
like yuck
can that be okay too can it be okay that
you have a preference where you're like
i don't necessarily like that
good for you like two things can be true
i can be like
damn good for you good for having
confidence in yourself
good for doing what you do girl good for
you and at the same
time i don't like it i think it's
disgusting i think those two things can
be
true you know what i mean you you know
you could praise someone for what they
do
and also be like hey i don't know if
this is uh this ain't my cup of tea
you know what i mean so i don't know
i listen i gotta i i was talking about
this on glassman's podcast and maybe i
wasn't clear enough but it's like just
because
you are attracted to a certain thing it
doesn't mean that certain thing
is something that is
you know healthy it's a better
pc way to say it you know it's like you
can have an
unhealthy lifestyle and sometimes you
can be attracted to that it's like women
who are attracted to men who are in
prison
you know they they like there's some
mass murderer and they're like ooh i'm
attracted to bad boys there's something
about him being in prison something
about the crimes he did whatever their
reasoning
is just because they're attracted to
that guy it don't make
being uh being in prison okay
you know it don't make it okay i'm not
saying being in prison is the same thing
as being fat
i'm just using it as an analogy of like
how we approach it
like we need to stop you know you know
it's like i just like to use the term of
like
just being healthier being healthier so
we can live longer and i'm thinking
about
these things because as i'm getting
older i'm starting to realize
like like after the move i mean i was
sore as hell my back was hurting my arms
were hurting my knees were hurting i was
like oh my god i felt like an old ass
man
i realized i'm not bouncing back as fast
as i used to before
and and then like you know i'm like
work i'm like moving towards diabetes
when i take these um
these blood tests and stuff and i was
like oh man so i gotta cut back on sugar
and breads and all this kind of stuff
and i realize
as you get older your body is you know
it's hard to deal with that and then i'm
starting to think about inflammation and
all these kinds of things because those
things lead to dementia
and those are the kind of things i have
to think about because my mom has
dementia
and i'm trying to be like oh i should
have i'm trying to do preventative
medicine
you know what's wrong with having the
mentality of that
having the mentality of like i'm
thinking about my future so when i look
at someone else and i go okay oh you're
25
26 and you you you are living an
unhealthy
lifestyle this is my perspective like yo
when you're getting close to
50 you can't just beat willy nilly with
stuff man
you can't just be willy nilly you can't
just be like oh
i'm doing me i love me for who i am i'm
body positive and i'm beautiful yeah
you're also about to die of like
something terrible so
you know you know that's all my
perspective
is but they always make it about you
know
oh you're talking smack about somebody
they always make it about like oh you're
you know you're you're being negative or
whatever it is whatever the whatever how
they however they
whatever narrative the karen's and and
and uh
pc police and the canceled culture
the culture culture those people however
they phrase it and they
present it they always coming across
like they're in the right
they never think in their minds that
maybe they're going too far
you know you ever think that that you
possibly
could be going too far maybe
i don't know it's crazy
uh-oh got a new beat let's play this new
beat from matic productions
is
oh
all right that's all you get
we need to cancel cancel cancel culture
that's what somebody said in the chat
cancel cancel cancel culture
i know it's crazy you know but by the
way
i also don't want to be these people one
of these people that's like oh
everybody's too sensitive young people
are sensitive i'm not going to be like
that either
you know it's okay that you like i'm
actually okay with you feeling the way
you want to feel
right keep that [ __ ] to yourself that's
my point or start a podcast like me
because
this is the point of having a podcast
that's getting your voice out and having
your message right
so okay you want to have your [ __ ] on
social media but i'm not trying to
tell you to i'm not trying to get rid of
you you know
i'm not i'm just trying to say like hey
mind your business all right
you don't like what i do i don't like
what you do we can still coexist
we can still live our lives and be like
just in disagreement
it's fine as long as you're not hurting
somebody you know what i mean
but people have this people have it in
their head that once they don't like
something
or it's not by the narrative that they
want
they feel like oh well we have to remove
that person from society
you know it's freaking annoying you know
i also want to say
i got since i moved to my new spot the
dudes from a hangover candle company
sent me
this dope new candle they don't even i
don't get no sponsorship from them or
nothing
i just like his candles this sucker
smells delish once i get it all set up
this is gonna be my new candle
anyway that's enough about canceling
cancel culture so
it is what it is it is what it is
um i don't know i think that's uh
all we got for this week guys i don't
know if you like this
chat what do you think should i just go
live on sunday nights with my reference
with griffin
and when i don't have a guest you know
or even even if i have a guest still go
live we're from a griffin so
um because this is again this is
actually literally how i do my podcast i
just turn on the cameras
i have some i have some things in my
head that i wanted to talk about from
before
and then i just come on here and i work
it out it's a way for me to clear my
thoughts clear my head
uh come up with material too uh for
jokes you know what i mean
i know i talked about my mom earlier i
did see my mom again it's hard i don't
know if anybody out there is dealing
with dementia in their family but it's
tough man
it's a tough thing to deal with because
you know you find yourself wanting to
avoid
seeing whoever it is you know especially
if you had a certain type of
relationship and it's my mom and it's
hard every time i see her
it's hard but she got this new thing now
so i picked her up and we went for a
drive
and like so we driving driving driving
then she sees a house
you know and she goes eric see that
house that's the house
i went to when i came to america with my
grandma
and grandma we went to that house and
she has a whole story about it you know
and i'm like where they live
this you know what i mean it's not true
you know what i mean but you know
dementia they gotta they live in a
fantasy world
about five minutes later we we see
another house and she goes
eric see that house that's the house i
came to when i first came to america
same story bought a different house
five minutes later another one after the
third one
i was like which house is a woman we
just passed three houses told me the
same story
now i should not have done that
but that is part of my problem that's
why it's
you know what and that's why it's hard
to deal with
because i i fly off the handle or you
know it's like
it's hard for my brain to accept this
it's just
i really every day i try to work on it
every day i'm way better than what i was
when when i first was dealing with it
because i would just argue right no your
grandma's dead
you know i would be like that but now
i'm like
i just let her tell her stories you know
tell me about oh
grandma she was like oh yeah like
thanksgiving she was like i don't know
why we're at this place
we should have went to my grandmother's
house because she cooks oh she she she
would have cooked
better thanksgiving and i'm thinking to
myself like you know
what are you talking what are you
talking about you know but but
new things are happening so she knows
i'm moving so and she said to me she was
like oh you're moving
oh so you're moving away from like some
street you know and it's a street from
where she came from
so she thinks i live on some street and
you know and i'm like
i'm like no and i still did i was like
no my i'm not remember i'm in cover city
but then i really have to just be like
oh yeah yeah
that's the street i live on and i moved
to this this other street
because i just need to stop because what
i realize is when i
contradict her it confuses her
and she and then and then she already
has cloudy thoughts
and she knows it too i could tell
because even when i said that thing
about the houses i was like wow even
though i was even though i was joking
because my mom was she's still
she's got a great sense of humor so we
joke my mom jokes a lot with me you know
so
you know you know so i could say i would
normally say something like that like
just the third time you said this woman
i could be like that with my mom
which house is it you know we laugh but
this time she she i just saw her that
she was like oh
well and then she was like oh never mind
you know and i thought to myself oh i
messed up
i messed up right there because she had
to think and she didn't wan
and it's hard for people with dementia
like it's hard to talk on the phone and
stuff like that because you know you
actually have to take the lead in the
conversation and just ask simple
questions and
keep talking to keep talking so they can
just gather information as opposed to
them having to come up with stuff
because when they have to come up with
stuff they get confused and that's why
they repeat themselves over and over and
over again so
anyway anybody out there dealing with
that i i feel for you
it is a tough thing to deal with
uh you know and again too it's like this
goes back to
what i'm saying about to to wrap it all
up you know
for me dementia it means something so
you know that's important to me because
i'm dealing with it what's important to
you
might not be something that i'm dealing
with you're not a monster because you
don't
care about dementia you know you might
be like oh you're indifferent to it just
like how we are with the homeless we're
indifferent
that's how people the way you treat the
homeless is the way people
treat your important issue especially
you karen's out there
you pc police people i care about your
issue the way you care about the
homeless it's just words
you're not really doing anything you're
not on you're not out there on the front
lines
and the ones that are i commend you
you're doing god's work and we should
all be better about trying to take care
of a fellow man
but don't act like just because i don't
care about something on the level that
you do
that one you're better than me or that
i'm terrible person no i just have other
things i care about that's all
there's levels we have different levels
that's all all right man
um we did it right
i think we did it i want to thank
everybody
uh that gave uh super chats today let's
go down the list
thanks to yikes thanks to jamie
mendoza thanks to brendan wilson
san jose shark and brad now thanks
people and thanks to everybody that
on my my very small very small patreon
i got like nine or ten people on my
patreon you know what i mean i don't
even think it's that many but those
people out there i really appreciate you
guys for being a part of that
i'm trying to put content up there it's
hard but we moved so now we got
this new place and rachel and i will do
some more content
because i want her to be on there too
you know because she's so funny like
we'll have these funny moments and i go
we should record this and put it on the
patreon
because she'll edit it together too
she's really good at that but
listen guys i really appreciate you guys
being here uh watching rifle griffin
live
the people that are watching live that
you just you caught it at the tail end
or you are i mean you're watching it now
because it's
because it's monday you know uh yeah
this uh this
podcast will uh it's gonna be private
and i'll put it back and actually i just
keep it up whatever it is it is what it
is i'm trying to figure out how to do
this
i don't know i don't know how to do it
moving forward but thank you for being
here make sure you follow me
i'm at instagram twitter at eric griffin
uh i game every day eric griffin gaming
on twitch and i put those video
on videos on youtube just got a dub with
my boy stevie wiebe my other friend
brian so i have that video up on my
gaming channel eric griffin gaming
and thanks for being here again on
riffing with griffin i got i got some
guests that i think i want to roll out
you know i'm not going to always have
guests but i'll have a few guests and
i'm just going to keep doing this i
appreciate the loyal fan base you guys
are really great i know you guys are up
late it's 12 30 a.m where i
am i don't know where everybody else is
but shout out to all you guys for
being on right now there's like 350
people watching live
so i appreciate that and if you want to
do this
if you want me to do this more often
just live episodes on sunday night
put it in the chat right there put the
comments put let me know what you not in
the chat but in the comments you know to
comment
that yes keep doing this keep doing this
and of course i'm still going to do real
world advice from a grown ass man i
didn't have any this week because i was
just so busy moving on the weekend but
thanks for uh watching riffing with
griffin thanks for being here live with
me
and you guys are
the best so let's go out with
let's go out with uh the singing mic you
know what i mean let's go out to see you
like
okay
always
[Music]
i'm like a vulture coming in on these
chocolates
[Music]
production beats now take your friends
spit these bars
oh
live
here we go here we go
thanks for being here
we again it with your friends
[Music]
[Music]
all right y'all thanks for watching and
i'll see you next week this is episode
113 griffin live
[Music]
peace
you